hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host John Carroll and I
don't know about you but most people I
know think of themselves as good people
as the good guys in the cosmic struggle
between good and evil most of us think
that we are trying to be good right I
mean this is a flaw in many movie
villain scenarios is that they're Dr
Evil types they're trying to be evil
whereas most people don't think of
themselves as evil people think of
themselves as good and yet they end up
disagreeing about what it means to be
good and how one should act if one is
good so there's a philosophy question
here obviously what does it mean to be
good to be moral to do the right thing
and we've had discussions about moral
objectivity versus constructivism or
what have you there's also a
psychological and neuroscientific
question about why people want to be
good and what is happening in them
psychologically when they think they are
being good that's where we are today in
today's conversation we're talking to
Molly Crockett who is a psychologist and
neuroscientist who studies morality as
it is actually practiced in human beings
so not necessarily trying to decide what
you should do but understanding why
people are trying to do the things that
they should do or how they come up with
the idea of what it is to do the right
thing is it ingrained in us do we learn
it is it something where there are
evolutionary explanations for this and
very importantly how can we change our
personal views on morality you know we
do learn things as we grow up maybe
there are things that when we were kids
we thought were perfectly moral
behaviors and now we've changed our
minds and as Molly points out there's a
very crucial modern question about how
technology and communication in the
digital age is changing the way that we
think about morality we we're faced with
a set of circumstances in an environment
that we were not evolved to understand
where things are very very rapid in how
they appear to us and how we can respond
to them and they are manipulated by
politicians and algorithms and so forth
ginning up outrage or for that matter
bringing us together in different ways
so there's a mixture of not just
morality but empathy ethics politics and
so forth so again it's a very very
mindscaping kind of set of questions
that come together when you say what
does it mean to say that we are moral
why are we doing that how does it
actually play out and Molly is not just
a psychologist who collects data from a
lot of different ways you know
psychology experiments watching people
in the field and so forth but also has a
bit of a philosophical background in
fact we we met at a philosophy
conference even though neither one of us
has a degree in doing philosophy because
velocity brings everything together so
there's going to be some talk about that
as well so let's go
[Music]
thank you
Molly Crockett welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you it's a pleasure to be
here so you think about morality but
rather than the philosophers we
sometimes talk to uh you're mostly a
psychologist I know that you hang with
philosophers that's okay that's good but
so therefore I would I would presume
that you're more interested in how we
reason morally as a matter of fact
rather than how we should reason like
what is the ultimate true theory of what
is right and wrong I mean I'm interested
in both and I think that ideally the
work can find how the data can inform
the theory and vice versa but yeah I
think that mostly I'm in the business of
the description as opposed to
prescription and so how does it work you
know it boots on the ground as it were
are you experimenting are you like going
into people's brains or giving them
psychology tests we use a lot lot of
different methods in our research
ranging from asking people to read about
hypothetical scenarios and make
judgments about them to experiments
where people are making real decisions
that have material consequences for
themselves and other people to
naturalistic Observation studies on the
internet like how people Express moral
outrage on Twitter to going into the
field and looking at how people's moral
cognition changes at festivals like
burning man and other other types of uh
transformative experiences so really the
whole uh range okay I mean you have to
give us a little bit of a hint about how
people's moral judgments change if
they're a burning man than if they're
you know at home well
um in in that line of work we have been
interested in in a phenomenon we call
moral expansion which is about you know
the the orientation of morality is it is
it directed towards your near and dear
or is it expanded to you Encompass all
of humanity and what we find is that
with every passing day that people spend
at an event like burning man the more
they feel transformed and the more
expanded their moral circle is to
Encompass you know everyone wow that's
actually very interesting and is that
would we attribute that to the sort of
common feeling of being in the group at
some kind of festival or is it more
there's certain substances one imbibes
in these instances to change how you
think
we don't have a very precise answer yet
and of course there are any number of
factors that can contribute to moral
expansion at um at multi-day Mass
Gatherings like burning man that we've
studied
um you know the sociologist Emile
durkheim coined the term Collective
effervescence to describe the the
feelings of you know uh really joyful
exuberant
um expansive connection that we feel
when we come together in large groups
for a common purpose and we think that
that that has to be part of it it is
true that people do consume uh
mind-altering substances at floating man
and other Mass Gatherings like this but
not as much as you might think in fact
and in our studies we really carefully
controlled for the substances that
people reported using and what we find
is that yes as you would expect people
are more likely to report having a
transformative experience
um after recently
using psychedelic substances over and
above any type of substance use we find
that that the more time people spend
that at uh these Collective Gathering
events they they feel transformed and
positive emotions and so on we we should
mention because you're using the phrase
transformative experience that we did a
podcast interview with Lori Paul back in
the day so anyone who wants to really
dig into the philosophy of that uh can
check that out and uh but but I like
what you're saying here even though this
is not at all what I planned to get into
first but um we have this feeling I
guess that there's a mob mentality that
can take over and usually that has
negative connotation so in some sense
you're giving us the positive side of
that communal feeling that we can get
yeah and I think that that what we can
learn when we take together our research
and and other similar research on the
the positive uh effects of mass
Gatherings
um as well as the Dark Side of mass
Gatherings ranging from you know mobs as
you say to you know Nazi rallies in the
Third Reich to more recent rallies on on
on the right that we've seen in the U.S
um you know we are story creatures we
are really really responsive to the
narratives that we tell ourselves and
others about human nature and I think of
mass Gatherings as amplifiers so
whatever the story that's being told the
culture of a mass gathering in terms of
how we treat each other what is our view
of humanity is it basically good is it
basically evil
um whatever that story is being promoted
the mass Gathering is going to amplify
it and that builds a culture here that
that is going to profoundly shape
people's thoughts feelings and behaviors
that's a very interesting point we also
recently had Michael tomasello on the
podcast and of course he oh great yeah
pushes this idea that the social
abilities of human beings is really what
sets them apart or enables all the other
things that set us apart and I guess
morality is is part of that you know we
I I'm guessing what do I know I'm a
physicist but uh we can feel connected
to other human beings in special ways
due to those social capacities
absolutely and okay with that on the
table that was very interesting I just
couldn't help but ask but let's let's
back up and be a little bit more basic
what do we mean when we talk about
morality uh do we even agree on what
that's supposed to mean oh no
that question actually because I don't
have a good answer for it and actually
morality morality is a more specific
term oftentimes
um I I Am shifting more towards favoring
the term Norm psychology or normativity
which which concerns how people think
about what is appropriate or or
inappropriate what is allowed or
disallowed within a society and of
course these are all social
constructions we know from research on
sort of the continuity between
social cognition and the animals and and
and what we have as humans which you
know Michael tomasello is is one of the
leading Scholars on that that there are
like you can trace a line between sort
of arm what you might call moral
sentiments in humans and things like
empathy care
um and and concern in you know other
mammals
um but aside from those really really
basic domain General building blocks of
normativity or morality there's
tremendous variation uh within and
across cultures in terms of like how we
think about what is right and wrong how
we talk about it how we enforce it how
we learn
um and so I'm I'm really really
interested increasingly in that in that
social construction that that cultural
side of norms and where do they come
from and do we have control over them
and crucially how is technology changing
the way that we think about right and
wrong the way that we enforce moral
Norms on other people and internalize
those to regulate our own behavior
that's good because we're going to
answer all of those questions in the
next hour so I'm glad that you have
raised them but it's a very good point
to switch for from sort of morality talk
to Norm talk because morality talk does
kind of presume we know what is moral
and what is not and people disagree
about that I mean is the disagreement I
guess where does it all start in in
development when we're kids are we born
somewhat moral creatures or at least
with with something we would recognize
as Norms or those taught to us I mean
there's still a lot of debate about this
um we we are born with a capacity to
learn particularly to learn in a social
sense so learn through observation
and learn from social feedback so you
know if you if you ask you know Scholars
of of human nature like what is most
distinctive about humans
um it's not necessarily morality or
Norms but rather our unbelievable
capacity to learn socially and not just
to learn and adapt within our lifetime
but to transmit through culture
Knowledge from generation to generation
and I think that it's not a coincidence
that the that we are such Norm focused
creatures because you know social
cohesion is really important for
survival cooperation gives us an
advantage over you know other species
many people have written about this and
and this is not directly what I work on
but I think in particular the the fact
that we care so much about what others
think of us and are our well-being is
you know for most people is really
really tied to our sense of like how how
am I fitting into the social world what
is my social standing and so you know
our ability to represent and learn about
Norms is a really crucial part of that
calculus that we are all making all the
time like am I doing the right thing am
I fitting in where we get into trouble
is where the the question am I doing the
right thing gets disconnected from
actual flourishing and Welfare of humans
and other species and I think in
particular what we're seeing today as
there's just massive amounts of of
normative discourse on social media what
we're seeing in real time is this really
really almost Rapid Cycling of proposals
about new things we share about backlash
to those proposals backlash to the
backlash backlash to the backlash to the
backlash to the back lash and so on ad
in pin item and so I'm really interested
in this process starting from the seeds
of moral cognition that we can see not
just in babies but also in other mammals
empathy
um and and and altruism but but then the
layers that get put on top of us as we
learn and grow and talk to each other
and talk to each other about what we're
talking about and so on and um it's it's
fascinating and also deeply troubling so
you know it's a really
um it's a really intense time to be
studying this kind of thing you know
there's always some time lag between
when you record these and when they're
released but as we're recording this the
thing that is going crazy on Twitter is
gas stove discourse I don't know if
you've listened in on gas stove
discourse but there's this idea that I
have not the government is going to ban
gas stoves in our houses they're not of
course really but they're they have
pointed out some people have pointed out
that there are Health uh challenges that
you can have deleterious health effects
from having gas stoves and so maybe we
should try to minimize them or try to
control them or whatever and so this is
ginned up outrage because people are
like you're never gonna you'll drag the
gas stove out of my cold dead hands I'm
sure that'll be forgotten this is such
this is such a good example of how the
the way that social media algorithms are
designed which is first and foremost to
grab our attention in order to keep us
online for longer in order to make the
most money and by definition the stuff
that captures our attention is
information that's really extreme that
provokes outrage even if that
information is super far-fetched or not
representative at all of how most people
think or what's likely to happen in the
future and so so then you have this
discourse and meta discourse around
pieces of information that may be very
very divorced from like things that will
actually affect our lives and uh and I'm
I'm I'm really interested in
understanding more about why this
happens and can we do something about it
and if so what should we do about it
because you know it's I get the question
all the time and I'm going to preempt
you asking me this question which is
like how should we redesign social media
and it's like it's a hard question
because it is a should question it's a
prescriptive Norm kind of question and
to answer that question you need to not
only understand the Dynamics of how
social media as it is currently designed
is shaping discourse and behavior which
we you know still you know this is such
a new area of research but then also
like what are you know what is your meta
ethical theory of like what is what is
the right way that Society should be set
up and you know that's that's all really
really tricky stuff that is a difficult
one and I will add in there to the
difficulty the fact that these features
of social media can be weaponized by
political actors right I mean they will
exaggerate the extent to which a certain
bad thing is happening because it gets
their base outrage that's what they want
yeah okay so there was some there's a
bunch of things that went by there in
your very nice discussion of that about
you know you're talking about morality
in a way that as a psychologist gets
down to how people act and how they talk
about how they act Etc not in some
objective moral realist sense I mean
probably well let's put it this way it
makes perfect sense that Norms develop
over time right through Evolution and
things like that and we give them the
label of being moral Rights and Wrongs
do you feel a need to take a stance on
moral realism versus relativism or
constructivism or something like that I
mean I I do feel it
dance and I also feel
undereducated in the ability to take a
stand I'm not trained in philosophy I
wish I was I actually you know
philosophy when I was in when I was in
high school I like dreamed of going to
University to to take philosophy and I
signed up for a philosophy class my
first semester I think it was a
philosophy of Mind class I don't
remember who the professor was I went
the first day and I was like what is
this like I want something real to
correspond to where is the data so I am
I you know majored in in Psychology and
Neuroscience and have been really at
home in those fields but but you know
increasingly gravitating towards
questions around morality and
normativity and as as my career has
progressed I have come to increasingly
identify as a philosopher and I think
I'm reading as much philosophy now as
I'm reading psychology and and
Neuroscience and and and I I just find
it really really rich and helpful and so
you know one of my sort of like to do
items that I uh hope to have time for at
some point is to like audit a moral
philosophy course or seminar because I
really like my my knowledge is not not
top down it's like it's very it's
magpie-ish I like have these little like
bits and pieces of of
understanding but um I don't feel like I
am educated enough to take a Firm Stance
but I I want to be more educated to be
able to move towards that have you heard
of and this is very unfair given what
you just said but have you heard of what
is called The evolutionary challenge to
moral realism I think so yes
um I think so yes basically the idea
that we would through Evolution develop
Norms that and you know think that there
are certain right things wrong things to
do and wouldn't it be weird if those
just happened to coincide with some
objective moral reality like that seems
like too much of a coincidence
right yeah but anyway you personally
don't need it right like you don't need
to care whether or not there are
objective moral standards out there
because if you're if what you're just
interested in are how people think about
morality themselves and how they justify
it I'm guessing
yes and no
um I I used to think that um and I I I
am increasingly becoming skeptical of
this divide that exists between science
on the one hand and values on the other
hand
um it's it you know it's it's a it's a
pretty common uh sentiment in moral
psychology that like oh our work cannot
speak to normative questions like we're
doing the description you can't get an
off from an is and so on and like at a
surface level that's true but also our
values in infect the way that we choose
to ask questions the questions that we
ask so you know just to give a concrete
example
um a very popular area in
um in moral and political psychology
right now is how can we get Democrats
and Republicans in the U.S to talk to
each other yeah more and how do we
Bridge these divides and you know can we
get people to meet in the middle and
compromise how do we get people to do
that and that is a a project that you
know has values in it in the sense that
there is a um there is a goal to get
people to meet in the middle right
um and on the surface that seems like a
really great goal and um in many many
cases it is a really important goal and
what if what if that goal is applied to
getting
um Nazis and liberal Democrats to meet
in the middle like like no if one side
is just right eating in the middle is
not the right thing to do you know I
mean I just think about like especially
when you're studying questions of of
morality and ethics it's really
important that we understand how our own
values shape the science that we do and
we are not trained to do this in science
we are told through our training in
science that science is objective and
science is free from values and like we
are humans and so of course it is it
um and and so you know a lot of a lot of
the work that I'm thinking about now is
like how should we be thinking about the
scientific Enterprise
in a time where values are so you know
they've always been important but in it
you know increasingly science is is
looking at questions that are very
related with values and so
um you know I like it's it's a it's a
challenge for sure well you know I think
this is a really good point because a
lot of the times we say well we're
objective you know we're not depending
on this or that values but really what
we mean is I know what the right values
are and I'm going to use them right and
most people agree with me so I think I
can get away with it
yeah so do people is there I mean so you
I think that you you've put your finger
on this distinction we draw between
values and
um objective truths and so forth there's
a bunch of distinctions out there that I
wanted to ask you about I mean one is
this idea that
um morality serves as a check on how we
would really like to act right like as a
psychologist is it is it accurate to
think of people as like these bundles of
terrible impulses that that morality
sort of sits on top of and prevents us
from doing all these terrible things no
okay that's an easy that's an easy
answer and you know I know like that's
not to say that we are you know
fundamentally Angelic either you know
what what we are fundamentally is social
Learners and the the beliefs that we
have about other people our group our
culture really impacts the way that we
comport ourselves intentionally and
deliberately which is you know on top of
or in concert with Basic Instincts that
we have which include a Basic Instinct
towards empathy and altruism and so you
know there's some really beautiful work
by my colleagues Julia Marshall and Paul
Bloom and this this goes back to the the
sort of universalism versus more
parochial morality and
um if you look at very very young
children versus older children versus
adults and how people show favoritism in
terms of
um thinking there's an obligation to
help family and friends more than
strangers that's something that develops
with age so very very young children
think you are equally obligated to help
a stranger versus a friend or family
member indeed
um but it's it's you know this
favoritism towards people who are more
close to us isn't something we're born
with it's something that we learn from
our culture
um and so that's just one of many
examples of like there there is a basic
goodness that that that people have we
learn
uh through interacting with others and
from our culture that you know there are
other other ways of being
um but you know this this myth of of
selfishness this idea that you know homo
economicus like people are basically
selfish everything can be explained in
terms of self-interest this is this is a
narrative that is not grounded in
science and I will add is like very
convenient for capitalism
um I've noticed that yes what is the
point of caring about other people if no
one else cares and you know it's it's
really easy to fall into these
self-serving narratives about human
nature and I worry about the broader
implications of those narratives like
what if we're telling stories about
human nature that that a are like
oversimplified and not really grounded
in in scientific data and B create
self-fulfilling prophecies where it's
like oh everyone is selfish so like
there's no point in me like wasting my
time to you know join a movement or
demand better treatment for people who
are less well-offs than me and so on
well I I have absolutely heard and
familiar with the idea that we're not
inherently selfish like that that's
pretty clear we have selfish impulses we
also have altruistic impulses but I
think that your claim that or your idea
maybe I don't know how much of it is
your work and how much you were quoting
other people but our sort of sphere of
caring
shrinks a little bit as we as we learn
and age I mean Peter Singer talks about
the expanding Circle as we get smarter
we you know we care about more people
um Nicholas christakis was on the
podcast and has an idea that it is the
social beings naturally have an in-group
bias
um but you're saying that I mean how
dramatic is this claim is there no
in-group bias when we're born is that
all given to us by culture or is that
something we don't know ah so that I'm
glad you asked because I think there's a
there's a Nuance here that's really
important
um the work that I'm referencing I think
is is is is concerning sort of how how
people feel about social obligations uh
towards close versus distant others like
within a group there is also separately
an in-group bias okay that is is
naturally
um that seems to be like pretty
Universal and and is detectable from a
young age and so I think that the the
puzzle or the challenge as we are in a
global Society where the challenges that
we Face pandemics climate change Etc
like our Global in nature like how do we
conceive of humanity as a giant in-group
and that is that is a challenge and I
guess this leads right into something I
also wanted to ask which is how much do
our moral impulses I don't even know
what to call them moral inclinations
impulses intuitions uh not quite you
know our sort of formal philosophy class
moral systems but our feelings how much
do they change over time and how much
can we change them intentionally by
thinking oh that my morality was wrong I
gotta change it great question and I
think there are a lot of different
directions we could go at answering it
so the short answer is that I think we
you know we come with a sort of a a
basic toolkit of moral sentiments like
empathy uh you know vicarious Joy uh you
know an Attunement to the pleasures and
pains of other people and the learning
that takes place on top of that is like
how do we how do we direct or tune or
shape those basic sentiments to the
social context right so like you know we
are not born knowing who is in that
group this is something that we that we
learn although there is there is some
evidence for for sensitivity to basic
cues like like language and and
appearance and so on but um but you know
political hatred for example is is
certainly something that is learned and
um we learned to direct our empathy more
towards
um in group versus up group members on
the base of ideology for example and I
do think that there I do think that
there is scope for changing the the the
cognitive mechanisms of normativity of
morality like on a cultural scale and I
think that that two mechanisms through
which this would work or two channels
might be what what we could call
representation and reinforcement
learning so representation right like we
we are conformists in the sense that
like we learned through observation when
other people are doing stuff we also
feel inclined to do stuff
um and
um one thing I've been thinking about in
our work on on social media discourse is
like if algorithms promote a particular
type of moral frame and that's whatever
everyone is seeing disproportionately in
their feeds can that influence the way
that we think about you know over time
moral situations so for example if there
are archetypes of villains where stories
of you know particular types of people
uh committing
you know bad Deeds are more likely to be
elevated and we all see that do we then
lower the threshold in our own lives for
you know seeing felony from those types
of people because that's what we're used
to seeing in our feeds and the
reinforcement learning side is like to
the extent that we participate in the
discourse and then the algorithms reward
us for that
that form of discourse like outrage the
more outrage we express the more likes
and retweets we get and and also of
course the algorithms are learning to
show the content that we post to the
audiences that are most likely to
comment on it and so you know what we
have now that we've never had before is
algorithms intervening on social
learning processes and cultural
Evolution uh in in a way that that I
think is new and you know in sort of
discussions of Technology there's always
a question like is this really new
though like what about what about the
printing press what about mass media and
like yes a lot of the effects that we're
seeing are more of the same
um and it's really important to to
consider all the scholarship in media
studies that predates the internet age
and I think that what is happening now
with algorithmic intervention on the
discourse that we are having with one
another is something that's new and is
something that that I worry about
because if you have an algorithm
designed to make money for tech
companies that is that is rewarding
certain types of Expressions it's a
rewarding certain types of stories that
we tell about right and wrong in our
culture then it seems obvious that
through reinforcement learning which is
a really basic process that like even
sea slugs have like we're gonna change
our Behavior over time and from
generation to generation like what is it
that we are teaching new generations
about how to think about right versus
wrong and what does that mean for the
future of politics and you know our
ability to cooperate and solve all of
these like really thorny challenges that
we face so these are these are the
things that keep yeah and even maybe
this is just too obvious but even just
the speed of the interactions right I
mean when I put a tweet up within half
an hour I know what the reaction is when
I write a book it's going to be months
this is very frustrating yeah yeah and
the speed is a really really interesting
aspect of it and
um I think that the speed has
contributed to uh two things that are in
in opposition to one another on the one
hand you have a a Rapid Cycling of you
know what you might call moral learning
or or or you know moral Evolution where
you know someone identifies a harm that
hasn't been identified before maybe it's
gas stoves maybe it's yeah
um maybe it's something else
um and then there's Discord just about
it and if that were taking place over a
a typical you know like a a pre-internet
age time scale like there would be time
to sort of digest and and
um and reflect and and what we have now
instead is like whoa what is happening
like it's really important to me to not
be a shitty person and to know how to
avoid harming others and and there's
this constant bombardment of
new things that we need to know about
and I think that one reaction is just
this is illegitimate I think there is a
backlash that comes from the speed
because we are used to you know social
or moral progress or change happening
over a course of decades and what we are
seeing now is a much much faster time
scale and I think that there are some
people who are are just responding to
this as as if this is illegitimate and
like one of the question of like the
question of whether it is legitimate or
illegitimate is is sort of separate but
like I I think that a lot of the like
backlash against like oh this is just
woke cancel culture like this is like
this is a very common refrain right like
like this is not real this is just woke
cancel culture like let's unpack that
like like what do you mean like like I
think that there's something happening
that I I want to understand better where
there's this like nihilistic kind of
um attitude towards new proposals about
how to treat each other better it's like
I just learned about it yesterday
therefore like this can't be real and I
think that's really interesting
um like a question to ponder yeah I mean
the speed and the algorithms these are
two things working in concert in the
social media world that are things that
we did not evolve to understand and deal
with very well right so it will be
interesting to see where we go forward
there is a related question there I mean
basically what I'm going to say is
there's something that I've said many
times and I don't know whether it's
right or not so I'm going to ask I'm
going to fact check myself with you
which is as someone who is not a moral
objectivist a moral realist uh I
identify more as a moral constructivist
I think that we have moral inclinations
but then I also claim game that and and
what what morality is is just sort of a
systematization of those moral
intuitions and inclinations but then I
also claim that we can think about it we
can do cognition we can rationally
reflect and we can update and adapt our
moral inclinations so even though that
the the Wellspring of our morality is
something built into us or learned at
such a young age that we can't think
about it that doesn't stop us from being
rational about it as as we mature and
hopefully think more wisely yeah I I
think that that that is is reasonable
um I think that the the project of of
cognitive science is really to
understand like what are the constraints
on reasoning and learning that can align
or disalign a goal to you know progress
and you know how you define that as is
is is tricky and it's broad but um I
think a lot of times we think we're
reasoning when actually it's it's
motivated right so you know how do you
how do you separate
the the process that that I think most
people have which is like I want to
learn and I want to act in a way that is
you know compatible with my own
flourishing and the flourishing of of
people I care about and also you know
the world in general like how does that
goal get shaped in ways that we can't
see by systems of power that Trace back
generations and act invisibly and act in
ways that are are in in many uh in many
ways designed for us not to see them
right so like I think a lot about out
how our our whole moral cognitive
apparatus seems to be really set up to
identify victims and villains and all of
the research in moral psychology is
about how we judge the rightness or
wrongness of individual actions and
um all of the stories that we consume in
the media about wrongdoing are pretty
much like here's a bad person who did a
bad thing in his bed and this is you
know they should be punished and so on
but like what about systems what about
systems that constrain people's choices
such that they they can't help but act
in ways that cause harm to themselves
and others like how do you blame a
system like we're not like our our minds
are not really designed I think design
is the wrong word but like like we don't
really in like we don't have a good like
conceptual system for doing that but
like it seems increasingly and I think
the pandemic is a really good example of
this there was an article by Ezra Klein
that came out I think if you know
sometime in the first year the pandemic
um that that really influenced me the
title of the article was there no good
choices and like you know within
psychology we had been talking a lot
about
um about like how do we get people to
social distance more how do we get
people to like wear masks how do we get
people to you know individually behave
in ways that can like not infect other
people and prolong the pandemic and it
was this very individualistic focus of
like individuals are bad if they don't
wear masks and if they don't socially
distance but like that's totally
ignoring the fact that like our society
was not set up to deal with a pandemic
and our governments did not give us any
good choices to live our lives during
this phase and so like I think a lot of
the questions that we focus on
disproportionately in moral psychology
and in ethics are like a red herring
like a lot of this is not about
individuals it's about systems and so
like how should how can we think more
about that that integration it's a
fascinating point because it's it's
parallel to the discourse about
effective altruism uh you know we had
will mccaskill in the podcast and I mean
my initial attitude is well if I'm going
to be an altruist I would rather be an
effective one than an ineffective one
right like that just seems to make sense
but I do feel the strength of a critique
that says they're putting all of their
emphasis on you know charitable
donations and individual good actions
and things like that and even if you
agree with it it is distracting or
covering up the much more severe
systematic problems that we might
imagine dealing with yep and maybe it's
even is there a dark side of morality is
morality something that is purposed to
cover up things that we might argue are
bad I mean you mentioned sort of
Retribution as something that uh is is
part of our moral calculus in some way
punishment for evil deeds and I I I've
read you say that it's interesting
people will say we need to punish this
person to prevent them from doing
something bad again or from deterring
others but really we kind of like the
punishment we kind of like the idea that
these people are being punished yep yeah
I mean that there are so many
fascinating questions and in thinking
about motives for punishment and we
we've done a lot of work on this in in
various guises but you know the the
broader point from the study you
mentioned is that like some some of like
most of our behaviors are multiply
determined right like we we do something
and there are multiple motives that are
guiding us towards a particular choice
and then when we explain that choice
afterwards there are social forces that
incentivize us to pick the reason that's
the most like socially desirable
um to explain our behavior and I think
over time this creates narratives it can
be self-serving
um so you know in the case of punishment
like we we do have a taste for Revenge
it is something that I think
evolved in order to you know at the
group level like keep the social Norm
machine grinding along
um but for individuals it's it's not
clear that revenge and retribution are
helpful either for like teaching people
uh in the long term to
um to change their behavior for the
better or for individual well-being so
like you know there's this idea that
revenge is sweet and it's satisfying but
actually there's data is showing that
like if you hold on to grudges and
revenge like that's that's harmful to
your well-being as well
um and so you know we did these
experiments where basically we gave
people the opportunity to to punish
someone and they would never know that
they had been punished
um it was sort of like the economic game
equivalent of of waiter spitting in a
rude customers food in the kitchen
before they bring it out so
um in this like people people are are
willing to do that they will pay money
to reduce the payoff of somebody who's
behaved unfairly towards them even if
they never find out
um but then when you ask them to report
afterwards like oh why did you punish
um a lot of people are like oh I wanted
to teach a lesson even though like in
some of these cases like there is no
lesson being transmitted
um and in the case of um in the case of
a lot of like altruistic Behavior
there's there's evidence from from our
lab and and and other labs and just like
looking out in the world like people
like like people launder
uh ill-gotten gains to make themselves
feel better so you know the Sackler
family donated a bunch of money that you
know was was earned in in the various
ways and I you know I think I think also
you know in in the domain of climate
like green washing is such uh a
prevalent
um issue where you have these fossil
fuel companies
um who really should be like reinvesting
their resources into uh like away from
fossil fuels but instead they're like
spending a lot of money on public uh
relations campaigns like oh we really
care about the climate we really care
about the environment but meanwhile
behind the scenes are still very much
like trying to extract as much carbon
from the earth and burn it as possible
and like the science tells us that like
we just can't do that like full stop
like no
um so you know there's there there are a
lot of ways in which moral narratives
are used to
strategically direct people's moral
judgments or reputation about narrators
away from the realities of the
consequences of their choices that were
were interested in in how moral
narratives are essentially a kind of an
epistemic power move because what they
do is they impose the narrators
preferred structure of causation and
moral responsibility into the audience
and in many times the audience doesn't
even know that that is happening okay
I'm totally stealing the phrase
epistemic power move I like that so much
that is absolutely capturing something
real and and part of what it's capturing
is even at just an individual level
forget about the the corporations or
whatever people like to be a little
judgy of other people right and maybe
that's a tawdry impulse that we have but
if you can sort of dress it up as being
morally righteous then that makes you
feel better right absolutely and you
know there's there's some really nice
work by Jill Jordan and colleague
showing that um when you condemn other
people you are seen as more trustworthy
so there is a way in which you know
moral judgments and punishments act as a
signal to other people that you know you
yourself would not behave that way um
okay I can't believe that we've gotten
this far into the podcast without
mentioning the words deontology and
consequentialism right like these are
the first words I always say when we
talk about morality uh we had Josh green
on the podcast and he has this idea that
basically intuitively we're
deontologists right there are rules that
we think govern right and wrong Behavior
but he says when you get smart and you
become more cognitive and rational about
it you always become a consequentialist
and you know you think through the
consequences of your actions I don't I
find that a little bit hard to believe a
little bit too Pat I'm probably
oversimplifying a very complex story
here but but is is there some way in
which these categories of moral
philosophy map onto the ways that we
think about it I think that question is
hard to answer because you know it's
sort of a a question that's that's
begged by the design of the moral
psychology literature right up until
fairly recently the vast majority of
research in moral psychology has been
looking at how people reason about you
know utilitarian versus deontological
approaches to moral dilemmas largely
thanks to Josh who like you know was a
Pioneer in this field and like he found
this really really tantalizing question
that was very tractable to the existing
methods in Psychology and Neuroscience
um I have a slightly different view to
Josh which is that I think that there's
good evidence to suggest that um that
deontological reasoning is is is highly
rational in a social sense
um in that
um deontological reasons and decisions
are seen as more trustworthy
um by social Partners so you know if you
think about okay if you think about the
demands of
um social relationships especially close
relationships and the importance for a
relationship like the importance of
relationships for our well-being and our
ability to sort of function socially
um you know most people don't want they
their spouse or their best friends to
treat them just the same as any other
person and like kind of the entire
premise of close relationships is a kind
of prioritization and so what we find in
our studies is that especially when it
comes to close relationship Partners
people overwhelmingly prefer
um deontological reasoners over
utilitarians now that's slightly
different when it comes to
um uh like leaders or or people who are
in a role where it's their job to treat
everyone equally so we did some studies
during the pandemic looking at trust in
leaders
um who endorse deontological or
utilitarian approaches to moral dilemmas
that arose during the pandemic and here
what we find is a an interesting
distinction so utilitarianism can be
divided into sort of a like a positive a
positive dimension in a negative
Dimension so the positive Dimension we
call impartial beneficence it's the idea
that everyone's welfare accounts equally
um and the negative side is instrumental
harm the idea that it's that it's
acceptable to you know harm one person
in order to save right many other people
and what we find is that across um
across 22 countries that we surveyed
during the pandemic
um people prefer leaders who endorse
um impartially beneficent solutions to
dilemmas
um around around resource distribution
so you know we contrast a leader who
says we should keep at home medical
supplies vaccines and so on and the
utilitarian leaders like we should send
those resources around the world where
they're needed most and across these 22
countries people trust the the
utilitarian leader more the one who says
we should have this sort of Universalist
approach to research distribution during
the pandemic but when it comes to
instrumental harm it flips so in
dilemmas like uh like allocating
um limited ventilators towards younger
people versus elderly elderly people or
imposing lockdowns that will
um that will sort of you know trade off
the welfare of different groups of
people
um we find that people like people
distrust utilitarian leaders who say
it's okay okay to sacrifice the welfare
of one group of people
um in order to to save others so there's
this Nuance where it's not the case that
utilitarianism is like broadly preferred
in leaders it it depends on the nature
of the Dilemma but I mean going back to
the question about like is is
dantological uh reasoning irrational I I
I don't think that it it's it's
necessarily the case and especially if
we think about rational rationality in
an ecological sense like I think of I
think of deontological intuitions as
something that evolved as a way to um to
you know strengthen the the fabric of
society by uh close relationships that's
fascinating that we tend to trust people
who are deontological thinkers or or
actors at the personal level maybe not
the leadership level yeah there was a
funny tweet that went around a little
while ago about someone who said uh I'm
really looking forward to a superhero
movie where the hero is a
consequentialist not a deontological
because you always see you know in the
movies it's like yes I will save you
even though it means the universe might
be destroyed and I'm always sitting
there maybe I'm over trained if I'm
sitting there in the audience going no
actually you should you should let your
friend die because the universe might be
destroyed but that's not how we that's
not our impulses at a very basic level
yeah but it's not just our
um the views of other people that matter
here right one of the things that you've
been thinking about is how morality
affects our self-image right like like
no one thinks that they're immoral the
do they like I tend to think that
everyone thinks they're moral and maybe
they make mistakes and then justify it
after the fact but that it has to
interplay with our our image of
ourselves as trying to be good people in
the world how does that work well so I
mean I I think that on the one hand we
know a lot about this and on the other
hand there there's a lot we we still
don't know so I mean what we do know is
that morality is really you know crucial
for our sense of self our you know our
you know if Nina sterlinger has some
nice studies where you you ask people
um you know hypothetical cases where
someone has lost their sense of morality
or whether they have lost their memories
and are they are they still the same
person and and and what they find is
that is that you know people are more
likely to say oh that's a different
person now if their morality has
dramatically changed compared to if
they've lost their memory so so we know
that like memory is really integral to
our our sense of identity and you know
it as I was saying earlier in this
discussion like getting excluded from
the group is is you know deadly you know
you know it it you know in in our
ancestral environment it was literally
deadly like you couldn't survive without
the group and and nowadays it's still
deadly like like you know depression and
and and suicide and and
um and all sorts of of uh of Health uh
problems are associated with loneliness
and so social isolation right so like it
is it is deeply deeply important to be
seen as moral by other people here's
where I think that we are really stuck
with how our culture talks and thinks
about morality we have this narrative
template of like they're good guys and
they're bad guys and you know bad guys
do bad stuff to good guys
um and you know if you take together if
you take if you juxtapose there good
guys and bad guys and you must be one of
the good guys like you can't be about
like you cannot no one puts themselves
we have so many defense mechanisms to
prevent ourselves from thinking of
ourselves as the bad guy and suffering
happens like happens right so those
three things are incompatible because if
if if I am never the bad guy
and yet suffering is happening sometimes
because of me like how do we deal with
that so like I think that we're really
we we are epistemically under-resourced
to solve conflicts in our society both
like both at the interpersonal level and
at the societal level and
um it doesn't have to be this way and
you know I'm I'm Buddhist and I I I have
spent many years you know studying you
know meditation and Buddhist philosophy
and then you know there there are
alternative ways of thinking about the
self and thinking about social
responsibility
um this goes back to what we were
talking about earlier around like social
structures
um as opposed to individuals being
responsible for bad outcomes and and so
you know I am really really like early
in this project but I'm very excited to
think about the implications of changing
the way we View you the structure of the
self and moral responsibility for you
know interpersonal conflict and and
well-being and so on because I think I
think that the the nut that we need to
crack so to speak is like the cycle that
we're stuck in where like oh something
bad happened gotta find a villain I'm
not the villain so you must be the
villain and that just is this vicious
cycle that creates these intractable
conflicts both like in you know close
relationships but then also you know at
you know between social groups and and
and you know in politics and so on and
so like we we have to find a way to
loosen the grip of like the moral self
and binary views of good guys and bad
guys if we're going to solve these
really really complex problems that
involve systems and a lot of suffering
that like we all really want to trace to
one person so we can blame them and
Punishment them and it will all be
better but like that's not actually
necessarily going to going to solve the
problem and blaming the president for
the price of gas right like sometimes
not only is it good guys and bad guys
but just the idea that there is a person
to blame for things that happen it's not
always accurate exactly exactly and it
yeah but okay that's a big project to
fix that that sounds like something that
is deeply embedded in human psychology I
mean I was going to say the Ancients
could at least rely on uh mischievous
gods and Spirits to blame for bad things
that happened but I mean maybe maybe
that's a better system
well part of it is that we're not good
at dealing with Randomness either right
like some things some bad things happen
it's nobody's fault not even the
system's fault yeah is that something we
can train ourselves to be better I mean
if you're interested in the Practical
side of things as a psychologist like
how much do psychologists come up with
ways that human beings can train
themselves to be better at avoiding some
of these mistakes I mean we should do
more of it
um I think that the the incentive
structure of Academia is tilted more
towards coming up with your own pet pet
Theory and promoting it and getting lots
of other people to believe in it then
like actually solving problems it's one
of the flood systems yes but education
education is is I think the best tool we
have and you know I recently had the
mind-boggling like still can't really
believe it happened privileged to meet
his Holiness the Dalai Lama at his
residence in dharamsala and um we talked
about you know all this stuff the you
know the the challenges that we're
facing you know Perpetual conflict and
um why is it that we are so stuck in in
views of of Us Versus Them when really
we are all you know in this together and
um his one of his main agendas it seemed
from from those few days was like
education is everything like we we
really need you know
with each new generation there is an
opportunity again because we are such
prodigious social Learners and because
culture you know just as much Maybe not
maybe even more than nature and nurture
is is going to shape our behaviors and
attitudes towards one another and so
with every new generation there are
opportunities to give people the the
tools and resources to think about
themselves and others and problems in
the world and morality in ways that
might be better than what we have now
but the problem of course is that that
discourse is is shaped by systems that
are not optimizing for well-being
they're optimizing for profit and so
like how how do we break free of that
that's like you know that is very very
thorny question
probably need a sabbatical to really
tackle that one uh comprehensively but
it also you know there's a reflection of
a problem we talked about at the very
beginning of thinking of science as
completely objective and so forth I mean
I'm entirely on board with saying that
education is good and there should be
more of it but there's education and
there's education like what are we
educating people about it's not just the
existence of education but our
educational system doesn't always
prioritize the kinds of things I think
that you're pointing at that would help
people navigate these situations and it
also doesn't get enough money in this
country yeah you know it's like like
severely underfunded and that's you know
that is outside of my expertise but uh
clearly clearly a problem well near the
end of the podcast we always let
ourselves
um be a little bit more speculative and
and wild so uh you already mentioned
have I not been speculative not enough
well you were you we glanced at this I
wanted to come back to it the idea of
psychoactive substances I mean you
mentioned that an injury a brain injury
can change a person's memory but also
their sense of morality so can drugs or
maybe even diet or something like that I
mean what is that how should we feel
about that if taking a certain drug well
first I should ask you the question can
taking certain drugs change our views of
morality yes
um but it's not clear how long the
effect lasts and how large the effect is
um so you know there are many lab
experiments some of which I have done
that show you can sort of shift around
people's moral judgments and behaviors
if you change their you know their
neurochemistry acutely uh but you know
of course our neurochemistry is being
affected all the time by things like
stress and you know like our diet thing
things out in the world so you know it's
it's a it's a it's a moving Target think
there's an important distinction between
like what these substances are doing to
the brain in real time versus the type
of knowledge you can gain or like in as
Laurie Paul would say like an epistemic
transformation that can occur during an
experience with a with a mind-altering
substance especially you know
psychedelics I think are the the prime
example of this where
um they dissolve your sense of that they
can dissolve your sense of self they can
open up a really profound you know sense
of love and connectedness and
boundlessness with the entire universe
and many people who have this kind of
experience report that it it is
epistemically transformative it changes
the way that that you see yourself in
relation to others and then you know
following on from that it's personally
transformative in that like it can
change your values and so those effects
are lasting well after the the acute
effects of the substance have worn off
and that's what I think is really
exciting about the potentiality of
psychedelic substances is unlike other
pharmacological treatments in Psychology
like you know or in Psychiatry like if
you're depressed you'll get prescribed
in SSRI and you have to keep taking that
drug indefinitely
um to you know experience the the
effects which you know arguably are
maybe even not what they're cracked up
to be but like with a with a a
Psychotherapy
um assisted with a psychedelic substance
like there can be changes to The
Narrative of the self and the way that
you understand
reality that have potential I think to
carry on well beyond the time that
you're high so that's extremely
interesting and I'm I'm certainly
um very willing to believe that
even after you know the the neurological
effects of the drugs have worn off you
you report a different sense of self or
whatever but I I want to question the
self-reportedness of that is there
evidence that people actually act
differently long after they've done this
I mean maybe I'm just being overly
cynical here but I had this question
about meditation and mindfulness you
know I know people who have been very
into this and they claim it's very very
transformative to me they act the same
as they always did so maybe maybe I am
not actually as perceptive and so you're
the you're the expert here yeah so I
mean you're right that quite a lot of
the research that has been done thus far
on psychedelics and meditation and you
know attending Mass Gatherings like
pruning like a lot of that is relying on
self-report and a lot of the work that
we are doing in the lab is is Bridging
the self-report with behavioral measures
that some people might take as more you
know valid or or convincing
um so there's less data on this but
um so far the data does not seem to be
dramatically Divergent from
um from self-report data although like
it is much easier to say that you think
you change than to actually demonstrate
change and and what one one new line of
work where we're doing this is actually
about the ability to introspect so quite
a lot of
um quite a lot of work just that
meditation improves your ability to
to understand the inner workings of your
mind
but the the way that that has been
measured has been like self-report
questionnaires like how well do you
understand your mine and then after
people go through meditation training
they say better but like how do you
verify that and so
um in my lab there are several folks who
are working on developing more objective
measures of introspective accuracy so we
have people make a series of decisions
and we can use computational models to
extract the processes that they use to
make those decisions and then separately
we ask people to self-report like how
did you make those decisions and then we
can see how well those match up
um so I think that it's a really
exciting time in cognitive science
because
there are lots of new methodological
avenues for verifying the link between
self-report and and behavior and I think
actually that self-report I'm just gonna
come out and say I think that
self-report is underrated okay um good
and and I think that you know it has
been very popular in the behavioral
sciences to not trust it
um but I I think that that is an
oversimplified uh View and I think that
that we we have data that that will be
coming out um that that calls that view
into question and um I think I think the
really interesting question is like like
how
how can we Bridge the very very rich
reports that people can make about
themselves and their understanding of
the world with you know what what we
might call more objective measures but
like understanding this relationship
between subjectivity and objectivity is
something that I'm really really curious
about so so at least tentatively you are
willing to believe that people who
practice mindfulness or meditate are
actually better at introspection than
those who are not uh we have not that
run those studies yet but we are but at
least it fits in with the fact that the
idea that the self-reporting is is
somehow accurate if that's true yeah
well and also like the you know the
entire premise of Clinical Psychology is
that you know Psychotherapy is helpful
and that people are able to to report on
their thoughts and feelings and and and
learn to reason about them and and in
particular learn to wreck recognize when
thought patterns are divorced from from
experience
um so so yeah I think I think it's a
really interesting set of questions I
guess maybe I'm uh spoiled by or you
know prejudiced maybe is a better word
um by you know being very convinced that
psycho psychedelics and so forth can
have great therapeutic effects and you
know help uh with depression and PTSD
but then also I hear people claim to get
insights into the fundamental nature of
the universe and cosmology and physics
and I know that those are all just kind
of nonsense so I have to be a little bit
skeptical of these overarching claims
but maybe maybe what they mean by that
is different from how you understand it
and how you're understanding the
structure of the universe and cosmology
is informed by your your training and
research as a physicist and maybe what
people mean when they say they
understand the nature of the universe is
is more about like how do I fit into
this and what is the meaning of my life
and and what is the point of it all
um so you know I I think I think there's
room for both I think there's room for
both that's a very good uh can't argue
with that that's a very good place to
end so Molly Crockett thanks very much
for being on the mindscape podcast thank
you so much this was a really fun
conversation
[Music]